Material design is a system for
cross platform visual, motion, and
interaction design.
It employs our experience of
the physical world to make UIs
more intuitive.
>> It borrows ideas from print design
world to help drive simplicity and
beauty in UIs.
>> At a glance, it might appear as
another implementation of flat design.
While material rejects the tropes of
extreme skeuomorphism, it does bring in
physical world concepts like light and
shadow and rendering volumes.
>> Now the four main concepts
of material design, and
coincidentally the titles of
the next four lessons are.
>> Tangible surfaces, surfaces that
we can touch and react to our input.
>> Bold graphic design.
An homage to great typography and
print layout.
>> Meaningful motion.
Motion that guides and
encourages the user, and.
>> Adaptive design.
UIs that look great no matter how
large or small the screen is.
>> Now we mentioned
cross platform before.
While this is a course on Android,
material design is intended for
use on many different platforms,
such as the web.
A lot of the design principles you
learn about here will be useful
outside of just Android.
>> As in the first lesson,
I'll walk you through code samples that
will help you tackle the final project.